vamos falar de falar de propósito gente
conta duas histórias pra vocês
apresento josé josé o funcionário do mês
todo mês em que conhece valores da
companhia aliás os valores eles ficam
atrás do que a shine então não foi muito
difícil ele entender como era e é um
profissional promissor tanto que é ele
que é cotado para toda nova vaga naquela
empresa então coitada não consegue nem
esquentar a cadeira das seis meses na
função chama josé ali porque ele é muito
bom precisa dele e isso foi fazendo josé
crescer e por isso fazendo josé aprender
e por um muito por um tempo isso foi
muito importante para ele é só que josé
continuou mudando mudando mudando
mudando eo josé virou o funcionário
ideal para a empresa o executivo bem
sucedido trabalhou um tempão tem algumas
experiências bacanas e chegou no lugar
diferenciado e vou te apresentar o pedro
o pedro trabalha na mesma empresa que
josé
ele também é o funcionário durante todo
mês de outro setor
ele conhece os valores da empresa só que
diferente do josé ele conhece porque ele
entende os valores da empresa e ele
consegue inclusive aplicar e até ver que
o chefe dele não tem tanto esses valores
assim e ele é também um profissional
promissor e ele também é feito várias
ele também recebe várias oportunidades
de trabalho dentro da empresa fora da
empresa e por um momento ele vai
aceitando e vai crescendo e chegou um
momento em que o pedro fala perai eu
quero essa esse lugar dessa companhia
quero fazer é começar a se questionar e
começa até a falar desculpa pregado se
lembrou de mim para essa posição mas eu
acho que eu vou passar essa oportunidade
e ele começa a se questionar e vai
procurar amigo vai procurar a família
vai tentar entender o que está passando
na cabeça dele e ele escuta de tudo
então ele escuta pessoas que falavam
isso aí
aí pedro você tem que entender o que
você quer aliás é fama nem acho que a
gente vai trabalhar também está com nada
vamos continuar fazendo qualquer coisa
mas né
entendi que você quer e outras pessoas
falavam pedro você está ajudando essa
oportunidade desse lugar e que todo
mundo que essa oportunidade você não tá
vendo e pedro começou a entender por aí
não é um extremo não é outro extremo
como é que eu consigo organizar esses
dois então para muita gente o pedro é um
avô adu é mimado e para muita gente o
pedro era uma pessoa que precisava usar
mais é até porque a gente não dá pra
gente agradar todo mundo já vamos
começar por aí
então vocês devem conhecer muito josés e
muitos pedros eu tenho certeza que agora
a cabeça de vocês vocês devem estar
pensando quem hoje é zé quem o pedro ou
até gente será que a sua josé são pedro
eu conheço vários josé de várias pedras
inclusive um josé que é uma amiga minha
que eu não vou falar o nome porque
quando ela vai ficar bravo comigo uma
vez eu virei pra ela ela não gostava do
lugar que ela estava e ela sofria mas
ela trabalhava final de semana são paulo
domingo
eu falava que você quer que você quer
uma pergunta como na ampla né
eu quero ser diretora julie não não eu
quero saber o que você quer
não era para ser diretora tentava mudar
a pergunta você quer ser diretora pra
que a diretora que fazer essa pergunta
porque muitas vezes a gente não se
pergunta por que a gente vai fazendo as
coisas e às vezes alguém vem com uma
pergunta de fora e talvez seja a
primeira vez que a gente está se
perguntando as coisas então olhando pra
isso de novo e eles não precisam
responder a ninguém mas quem é o
super-herói quem é a pessoa é que a
sociedade precisa e quem é a pessoa que
as empresas precisam porque a gente tem
que falar de propósito
bom pessoas que sabem o que querem o que
sabem o que é importante o que sabem o
que os motivam e aí gente propósito eu
estou chamando de propósito você pode
chamar de o que te faz feliz você pode
chamar de é a sua missão de vida fiquem
à vontade para usar o termo que vocês
acharem mais adequado às pessoas que
entendem por que elas estão onde estão e
o que elas querem fazer com todo o seu
potencial
elas têm a oportunidade de entender
melhor as oportunidades escolher as
oportunidades e ser feliz com o que
acontece porque talvez ela tenha clareza
do que ela quer e do que ela não tem e
qual é o caminho para chegar o que ela
tem é que ela não tem ainda com isso ea
gente já falou em outras palestras aqui
que eu achei bárbaro porque todos os
temas aqui estão coletando é a motivação
vem de dentro
eu não tenho ninguém para me falar vai
nessa vaé é atingir essa meta atingir
essa meta porque eu tenho que atingir
essa meta mesmo quando eu entendo com a
importância disso
a motivação é minha e quando a motivação
vem de dentro é o meu impacto pode nem
eu pode passar a ter noção do impacto
que eu posso causar naquela naquele
naquela organização e na sociedade
e imaginem quando várias pessoas dentro
de uma sociedade pessoas ainda mais
agora de vários países diferentes com
internet e facebook todas as formas de
conexão e discutir e desenvoltura que a
gente também está falando hoje quando
elas se encontram
a gente quando ela se encontram várias
pessoas de propósito e que aliás é o que
está acontecendo aqui porque esse evento
foi sempre sendo organizado através de
pessoas que doaram seu tempo porque
tinha um propósito colocado o céu é o
limite que é o limite
ele estuda muito lindo mas tem alguma
referência que comprove que está falando
tem é e bárbara porque a gente acabou de
ver um tédio do daniel pink no qual ele
fala exatamente o que eu trouxe aqui ea
daniel que escreveu um livro chamado
drive e ele coloca como
os fatores motivado na motivacionais de
uma pessoa no ambiente de trabalho como
a autonomia maestria e propósito e uma
outra referência bacana eu já vi heyman
que ele escreve um livro escreveu um
livro chamado propósito que é voltado
para como as empresas podem se
posicionar com o propósito no mundo é
ele coloca ele faz ele traz alguns
estudos um estudo que ele traz o
relaciona a consciência do propósito
dessa empresa a reputação da empresa ea
rentabilidade no índice bovespa e ele
coloca que o que ele encontra foi uma
verdadeira roda da fortuna a gente
ganhar dinheiro a empresa ganhar
dinheiro não tem mal nenhum
o mec agora ganhar dinheiro com o bem da
sociedade e sua espetacular e é isso que
ele traz aqui quando ele coloca a
consciência de um propósito e um
propósito vamos combinar é pra meu
propósito bacana né
quando a gente identifica né como a
gente coloque em prática como a gente
nem fica o próprio propósito nunca parei
para pensar nisso que palavra estranha
eu até parei pra pensar o que eu queria
fazer quando me formei mas naquela época
às vezes a gente ver vocês né eu todo
mundo a gente não tem talvez é tanta
tanto conhecimento quanto a gente vai
ter ao longo nem e às vezes algumas
pessoas e param para perguntar um pouco
depois identifica o meu propósito
primeiro o primeiro seria não se
desespere
eu acho que é uma dica abra porque vai
demorar às vezes porque o propósito que
a gente acha que é que faz sentido hoje
num pode não fazer sentido em que há
seis meses porque a gente está o tempo
todo mudando o tempo todo se
reinventando e que bacana eu poder me
reinventar e que bárbara poder mudar de
idéia
então a primeira dica que eu dou é curto
caminho curto caminho e entenda as
oportunidades que estão surgindo pra
gente também não ficar bitolado em
alguma coisa que eu preciso achar um
propósito precisa já a motivação
isso é natural e ao mesmo tempo que eu
acho
muito importante é muito bacana ver uma
sociedade e vários jovens que buscam
tanto fazer sentido que a coisa faça
sentido para si como o que eu posso
fazer para a sociedade que é fantástico
eu também vejo uma leva de jovens que
fica se perdendo atrás de um propósito
ideal que pode demorar pra achar porque
eu como eu falei gente a gente muda o
tempo todo então a gente fica procurando
o propósito
talvez a gente encontre porque a gente
está mudando o tempo todo então esse é
um receio e uma reflexão que eu vejo
como pessoa e como profissional de rh
trabalhando em rh
então às vezes a gente precisa entender
as oportunidades e saiu um pouco do
caminho que a gente lançou porque pode
ser que o nosso caminho esteja
justamente nessa nessa virada nessa
virada para a direita
que tipo de perguntas a gente pode se
fazer um bom primeiro não é respondendo
esse questionário colocando na internet
ou indo passar o final de semana no
retiro que você vai descobrir a resposta
começa por aí
são perguntas que a gente tem que ficar
pensando e se conhecendo e tem uma
questão de auto conhecimento é
importante aqui ea gente acha que se
conhece até a gente começar a fazer
algumas perguntas difíceis então por
exemplo o que a gente faz bem que a
gente fez bem eu sei fazer eu sei o que
eu faço bem quanto você não percebe o
tempo passar
provavelmente quando você não percebe o
é quando você está mais envolvido e mais
motivado e de repente nossa já são duas
da manhã e eu estou aqui fazendo alguma
coisa em um projeto pessoal todo mês
fazendo um power point com as fotos da
viagem sai lá mas eu não percebi o tempo
passar então isso me dá uma motivação
quais são seus valores e aí é difícil e
não sei quais são os meus valores
quando você decide como agir como você
decide como não agir
isso vai te dar uma dica importante e
quem te inspira
por que te inspira a e verdadeiramente
nekemte inspira e aí pode ser pai pode
ser professor pode ser é referência
internacional
enfim é quem inspira nas nas coisas que
são importantes para você e e que eu
acho que é um dos fatores é uma das
perdas mais importantes e se você não
tivesse nenhuma limitação de tempo ou de
dinheiro o que você faria
a mineira mas é um tópico né vamos
combinar não tenho direito dinheiro
limitado e não posso pensar assim pode
porque se a gente não pensar dessa forma
a gente vai se alimentar já de partida e
não vai se permitir criar nada e aí
com tantas oportunidades de shelby
economy fraude fiscal saulim e n
possibilidades que esse mundo moderno
nos traz hoje e se não deveria ser um
limitador que você colocasse de partida
e sim uma categoria que você adiciona
depois prender como você resolve isso
feito isso gente se prepara o que é
agora fica mais difícil porque descobri
pode ser difícil agora começar a fazer o
que você quer que você ama que você
sonha que você tem propósito pra fazer
vai exigir esforço dedicação
persistência e vai ter que tirar
completamente da zona de conforto porque
você talvez em muitos casos vai fazer
uma coisa completamente nova
ou que nem todo mundo conhece ou que
exige vendas de fenda da idéia pra
pessoa então é a muitas vezes a gente se
reinventa quando a gente entende de fato
que a gente que inventa alguma coisa na
própria sociedade e que as empresas têm
a ver com isso
eu sou uma profissional de rh ia eu
acredito que a seja pequena seja média
seja grande a maior parte das pessoas
está empresa organização ou qualquer
tipo de organização é então a empresa
tem uma responsabilidade imensa tanto
incentivar as pessoas a entender o que
elas poderiam fazer o mundo melhor
quanto pra entender que poderia ajudar
essas empresas em um lugar melhor para
que essa empresa empate em um mundo
melhor
então não é simples fazer isso pra gente
imagina fazer isso para a empresa
então quais seriam os ingredientes
que eu colocaria para uma empresa poder
pensar em fazer isso de uma forma é bem
feita
primeiro se a empresa não tiver um
propósito é consciente claro definido aí
fica difícil pedir para qualquer pessoa
ter propósito é gente porque qualquer
lugar ou qualquer foco vai então pra mim
a questão sempre começa de cima para
baixo no sentido de que tem que se dar o
exemplo então se os executivos de todas
as gerações da empresa é não estiverem
bem fundamentadas e coisas dificilmente
essa empresa vai conseguir pessoas que
são bem fundamentadas e coisas
segundo a liderança que mesmo sem uma
liderança trabalhar numa organização que
é bem fundamentada e coisa com seu
propósito
se ele não foi bem fundamentada em coeso
é telhado de vidro ele não vai conseguir
ser nenhum exemplo nem desenvolver as
pessoas ou incentivar as pessoas no
mesmo caminho
então esse também é uma pena um tripé é
um fator importante
os colaboradores se a gente tiver uma
organização com várias pessoas que não
estão dispostas a se abrir a aprender a
olhar um novo e o mais importante também
mais difícil se conhecer
também não dá falta uma peça eo rh ou
área de talentos
o área de como a gente quiser dar o nome
mas uma área que possa suportar tantos
executivos quanto à liderança quanto os
colaboradores com a não processos mas
com exemplos e estímulos e projetos que
efetivamente vão ajudar as pessoas a
encontrar o próprio caminho
eu gosto de uma palavra que é humanizar
o ambiente de trabalho
humanizar o ambiente de trabalho a gente
não é máquina há muito tempo e eu vejo
que a principal missão do rh além é
claro de ajudar a empresa a gerar mais
resultado é fazer isso através da
humanização do ambiente de trabalho
e pra mim isso parte do autoconhecimento
e tem uma prática que eu sou muito fã é
uma prática milenar
uma das mais antigas e talvez uma das
menos valorizadas hoje no ambiente de
trabalho
na prática de meditação e demais e
fornece que em português significa
atenção plena
hoje em dia um tanto estímulo gente uma
pessoa uma vez falou pra mim helena
a gente está com tanto estímulo mas
tanto estímulo que daqui a pouco bem
mais caro da sociedade vai ser o
silêncio silêncio de propósito pra vocês
pensarem e é sério porque se em silêncio
eu tenho nem tempo de pensar pra mim de
pensar em mente voltar a atenção pra mim
de prestar atenção como eu estou
respirando para entender que eu tô
nervosa que eu não tô nervosa para
entender o que alguma coisa tem impacto
em mim e eu tenho visto algumas práticas
de meditação e tem estudado há algum
tempo sobre isso é dentro das minhas dos
meus anos de estudo e até é comprovado
científicamente que melhora a
concentração melhora o humor alivia o
stress e te ajuda a ter mais consciência
de si mesmo no mundo que a gente tem tão
pouco tempo e que a gente está tão
consumido com tenho que fazer isso tem
que fazer aquilo meu e mail tocando com
a tap a quinlan quem sou eu
então é uma pergunta importante então eu
acredito e acredito mesmo aqui quando a
gente tiver uma sociedade com pessoas
que são mais conscientes da sua missão
de vida ou do seu propósito
elas podem se encontrar com pessoas que
tenha é que também têm essa mesma
consciência e entender o impacto muito
maior que a gente tem para a sociedade
então a gente está falando de união de
sinergia de nós mesmo de prosperidade e
eu espero que não muito longe daqui não
muito tempo daqui que eu possa de
repente está conversando né na rua com
alguma pessoa como amigo e de repente
essa conversa de prosperidade e de a
propósito seja uma coisa tão comum que a
gente vai falar assim aliás faz de
propósito